et
[Musique]
les shadoks 9 atteint du mal de lune
refuge de pompey pour leur faire peur le
devin plombier et la vieille légende on
prédit la fin du monde pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le soi-disant dernier jour se lever
c'est aujourd'hui la fin du mythe
clamait le plombier pompe et
malheureuses bêtes vous êtes où ce soir
vous pourrez mais la fin du monde n'en
finissait pas d'arriver et les shadoks 9
vaquait à de bénigne occupations comme
si de rien n'était ce jour là il ne se
passera rien de spécial
le long de ma non plus d'ailleurs on
peut dire que ce fut même une fin du
monde assez calme 1
met le devin poopy s'acharnait pompe et
misérable berne 7 et hier la fin
d'humour un shadok qui ne pompe pas est
un chat document les autres répondent
elles comme l'escwa révoltante qu'il
était déjà mort depuis hier qu'un chat
de cours de la veille
un shadok pas la fin du monde comme ça
ne trouver cela tout à fait à leur
convenance et s'était même dommage
ajouté t-il cyniquement qu'il n'arrive
pas plus souvent pour leur apprendre les
bonnes manières un certain nombre
avaient été condamnés à mort mais ont
prétendument il l'était déjà
cela ne leur faisait ni chaud ni froid
on était obligé de les condamner à mort
mais un perpétuité mais avec tout cela
l'astral une avancée toujours pas le
grand départ shadoks vers l'infini
semblait assez compromis car ggn qui
avait souri à battre est de débarrasser
la terre interdite jadot qui restait
tiré là dessus à boulet rouge et de
toutes les couleurs
ninon viendrez à bout de cette calamité
d'astro lune d'ailleurs il ne perd rien
pour attendre il disait parce que de
mémoire de gégène on ne connaissait pas
d'exemple d'aéroplan qui soit rester
indéfiniment au lait pour la cinquième
ou sixième fois la fin des shadoks
apparemment avait sonné alors comme tout
semblait perdu et qu'il n'y avait plus
rien à faire
les shadoks décidèrent à titre de
représailles et faute de mieux de
condamner aussi à mort laquelle les
ondes qui avait menti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]